[Music]
I think one of the one of the big sort
of counterintuitive points that that I
draw in the book the fuzzy in the techie
is this notion that just because you
have technology skills doesn't
necessarily make you relevant in
tomorrow a sort of tech led data infused
economy and you know if you look at the
sort of underlies of jobs there are
tasks that are may make up every
different job that we have in each of
our jobs has some subset of tasks that
are wrote that are scripted that are
highly routine these are things that
over time we can either program robots
to do them if they're manual or we can
program machines to do them through
machine learning but there's always a
subset that's sort of more complicated
or more complex that requires
collaboration that requires
communication or doing things that are
on the frontier of what we haven't seen
before things that require improvisation
and those are the very skills those are
sort of the skills that require adaptive
or flexible learning and so I think the
counterintuitive point is that just
because you have rote technical ability
you may actually be more susceptible to
job automation than somebody that has
flexible thinking skills so it's sort of
this false dichotomy between having
technical skills being relevant having
soft skills being irrelevant in fact
it's more the opposite so I think that
you know when we think about automation
it it's necessary that we engage with
data it's necessary that we learn the
fundamentals of Technology we learn to
code we learn to speak this new language
but I think we can't forget as well the
soft skills that will you know enable us
to sort of whether the the changing
economy as machines continue to take
more and more rote and scripted tasks
away from humans so the progress we've
seen recently with things like deep
learning with the deep mind and alphago
and sort of playing the the world
champion and go these are fundamentally
groundbreaking type endeavors I think
the really interesting thing is that the
artificial intelligence we talked about
today still context-dependent
it's still dependent on being on a board
being within the confines of a set of
rules and so if you think about simple
tasks those
rules-based tasks that may be very easy
to automate we've sort of migrated I
think up the up the funnel where we're
talking about in immensely complicated
tasks but I wouldn't necessarily say
that we've transgressed into complexity
where there's really something that's
off the board off you know off the
chessboard entirely off the go board
entirely and so I think that when we can
move to a realm where we're not context
dependent to me that's sort of one of
the definitional qualities of when it's
truly perhaps artificial intelligence
and not sort of AI that's largely human
led or human guided so one of the new
technologies that is sort of in the
daily media today that we focus on a lot
is this prospect of self-driving cars or
automated vehicles on the roads and if
you look under the hood of this new
technology we realized that some of the
biggest challenges we're facing are
those that have to do with mixed use
environment so for example when people
sort of migrate toward this new form of
vehicle there's not going to be sort of
a zero to one change there's going to be
this mixed environment for a number of
years potentially decades where we have
self-driving cars
perhaps partially automated vehicles
included with human led cars and so one
of the biggest challenges is more of an
anthropological challenge or figuring
out how do we get machines to interface
with humans in an effective way so if
you actually look at a company like
Nissan some of the most important roles
that they're hiring for our PhD
anthropologists who are doing sort of
ethnographic studies looking at human
communication by a gesture or by you
know raising a nod or giving an eyebrow
wave and these are small things that we
sort of take for granted as implicit
ways that we communicate as humans but
if you're trying to transcribe that into
code and sort of teach an engineering
team how to write the computer code for
that that becomes a very difficult
challenge between sort of
anthropological research and engineering
and I think that this is a perfect
example of how we have to bring together
you know both the fuzzy and the techie
to really sort of meet some of the
biggest challenges today with
self-driving cars so I think in 2014 we
were at this
the height of fear where there had been
a study that came out with the Oxford
Martin Institute that looked at how 47%
of US jobs were at high risk of machine
automation this was also the year where
you know Martin Ford's rises the robots
came out and was sort of the pendulum
swung all the way to fear and I think
taking a step back earlier this year the
McKinsey Global Institute came out with
a study where they looked at 800
occupations and they drilled down into
those occupations and they looked at the
Constituent tasks that made up of each
of those jobs and they found that around
5% of jobs had a hundred percent of
tasks that were things that could be
automated potentially by machines but
the the more interesting conclusion was
that for roughly 60 percent of jobs only
30 percent of the tasks within those
jobs were things that machines could
sort of do over time and so as machines
take over the rote or the scripted the
routine aspects of jobs the things that
we've done many times before the things
for which we have best practices or good
practices things where you may have a
note on the wall that says do it
explicitly this order of operations
these 10 steps those are the things that
we can program machines to do in a
fairly easy way over time
there are obviously questions about the
use of internal teams and dedicating
resources to optimize certain processes
versus others these things aren't all
going to happen overnight I think there
are a lot of management questions that
have to do with resource allocation
around some of these issues so technical
feasibility is only the first step of
automation I think then there are many
more steps that we need to consider but
I think the interesting conclusion from
the McKinsey Global Institute is that
for these 30% of tasks that may go to
machines over time what this does is it
up skills or levels up the human where
we now have to focus on the sort of non
routine aspects of our job the complex
aspects and in this world of complexity
where you may be good at one thing and
I'm good at something else we actually
start task trading more we actually
start working on one thing for one
person one thing for somebody else and
in this environment of
increasing task trading there's a guy
named David Deming who is an economist
at the Harvard Graduate School of
Education and professor Deming talks
about how it's actually the soft skills
that reduce the friction or reduce the
transaction cost when we trade tasks so
in fact when machines are taking over
the rote or routine aspects of our jobs
and humans are left with this 70% of
complex or non routine tasks it's
actually the soft skills that start
becoming more and more important